[Music]
volunteering helps you move outside
yourself it helps you see that there's a
whole world of people who have their own
unique life stories forty percent of our
students are volunteering on a regular
basis on average volunteering 15,000
hours a year doing academic studies to
make yourself better to increase your
own knowledge base and I say that goal
program volunteering in general it's a
good look back at why we're here study
you know works year to invest in
ourselves so that we can invest in other
people so that we can good community
members so we volunteer you can for them
because that our makes a bigger
difference than it would have if I was
hanging out with my friends here it
means the world to someone else but you
consistently go back which we all my
life there are people who given up so
much for me to get an education or even
to basically eat and survive and the
least that I can do things asking
someone else so volunteers get out there
and they're doing it because it seems
like the right thing to do and suddenly
they realize this is an enjoyable thing
to do there's a scripture a verse that
says it is more blessed to give than it
is to resume and there's something about
instead of gear they're receiving that
so much more becomes infectious things
that I loved about volunteering or just
building long term relationships with
different people in the community go
home a very wide variety of places that
Kingston volunteers through a lot of
youth based programs at community sports
young life mentoring volunteering helps
me right now it helps me relate to
people better it helps me practice
compassion I think in the future I will
still be using the lessons that
learned volunteering right now because
they're universal and they're helping
everyone become a better version of who
they were created to be
you